so I want to start by I think the most
important thing I saw the movie last
night and I realized that the theater
that I was in must have been very dusty
because it wasn't the movie that made me
cry it was the dust in the theater right
right I think there needs to be a
campaign about cleaning movie theaters
before you show this well I think people
are finding it very emotional but I hope
I also find it uplifting and
entertaining 100% but there should be a
campaign yeah does yeah just throw that
out there um so Amanda loves dogs I just
did something with her she was a big
supporter of the best trains Animal
Society and I discovered that I mean
loves dogs so what was it like on set
with her because I would imagine there
was a lot of her just stopping
everything just to play with the dogs
well it's lucky she's such a brilliant
actress because as he say no one loves
dogs more than Amanda but she had to
play a character who isn't a big fan of
dogs so that was a real stretch for her
but she's so skillful she managed to
make it work they often say don't work
with kids and don't work with animals
and you worked with both what does that
present with a like a filmmaking
challenge when you have animals that you
know they're gonna do what they want to
do well I must admit I was terrified
because in this film there's a dog in
every scene and in most scenes that dog
has to do something very skillful and
very technical and there's a director at
the mercy of all that but these dogs
were some of the best prepared actors
I've ever worked with they were very
well trained and they were a joy to work
with so you did not hit like ten takes
on something very very occasionally I
mean more likely we did it all in one
take and we just sat by the camera
thinking my goodness did we actually did
that just happen it is perfect you know
and so I have to say it was a very happy
experience I'm always obsessed with the
editing process because it's the final
rewrite what did you learn when you go
in the editing room with your footage
that maybe you were surprised by that's
a good question because this is a film
that has a lot of elements at the core
of it it's a family story but it's also
a man and dog story and you know Milo's
character is a racing driver so there
a lot of quite ambitious racing footage
so no one really knew what it would be
like to put it all together but we had
this secret sauce in this film we had
obviously every scene we had a dog - cut
- and then moreover we had the dogs
voiceover performed by I'm excited to
say by Kevin Costner and when we saw the
film we were as we wanted even more
voiceover so we added lines and added
jokes for the the Kevin Costner's voice
and so in some ways it was easier than
other films I've edited because of the
dog because the voiceover and the shots
of the dog gave us these these bridges
to cut between sure did you end up doing
any test screenings and what did you
learn from them that maybe that impacted
the finished film well we did do test
screenings and they went very well and
was happiness it's a because that's a
nerve-wracking process part of the
process but what I really loved was how
much humor the audience found in the
film so you'd never know what's true in
the land and there were certain lines
and certain moments that got these huge
roars of laughter and so that was
exciting and the other thing that was
that even though it's an emotional
roller coaster the film it ends in a
very uplifting surprising way and it was
great to see how much the audience
responded to that surprising positive
ending totally I have to stop and again
I want to reiterate campaign to clean
theatres get rid of the dust Congrats on
the movie thank you appreciate that cool
thank you so much and thank you I hope
it's a huge it thank you thank you